at first glance it seems to be business
as usual in Athens despite the threat of
the country's default lines at ATMs are
no longer than usual well there aren't
any more people here than usual it's
mostly the older ones for any metal
arrows Olivia bought the numbers speak
for themselves Greeks withdrew more than
1.2 billion euros from their accounts in
the first week of june people are losing
confidence in banks and a large number
of people don't have much left in their
bank accounts anyway no support to be
honest I haven't gone any money in the
bank it's like that for a lot of people
I don't have any money anyway just debts
wages haven't been paid in weeks savings
are running out while many people are
just resigned to their fate those who do
have some money don't know where to
invest it gold is no longer considered a
safe haven people are terribly worried
about their future as the crisis
drawings on so they take sometimes money
they hold it up home so I heard some
people that were thinking about buying a
small flat or a car because they don't
know what to expect Limited clarity is
the the way I would describe the
situation right now
a majority of the population is still in
favor of remaining in the euro even if
there's no political solution in sight a
grexit with unpredictable consequences
it's a political nightmare sailor
bushing news I hope that doesn't happen
we're all in the same boat in the end of
a person but it would be unfair the
people have put up with a lot if there's
enough adorable babe there's no feeling
of panic in the air in Greece yet bought
Thursday's Eurogroup finance ministers
meeting could prove to be a turning
point